[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est bien un plateau il
ya des clashs et hier soir encore
boubakary avec lui c'est d'écrire
invités plus d'un million six cent mille
personnes est vrai que sur ce plateau il
ya eu du clash aurait dû aider du bon
classe même même mois et même vous mêmes
tout le monde d'ailleurs il sera là dans
ces clashs et on vous a fait un petit un
petit magnéto qui est ma foi très très
fort
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que on à raconter des inepties
inepties sur l'ineptie dont contre l'
amalgame d'isabelle qui n'a pas été
compris entre benjamin castaldi
excuse moi qui relaie des fakes news de
la fachosphère en parlant d' apologie au
terrorisme ou en prêtant des proxys en
prêtant ses en prêtant une proximité
tu va retirer tout de suite en prêtant
la conduite non je plaisante pas là
entrée te colle alors je présente pas
turquie a tout de suite
malheureusement c'est les sources d'un
jamin bazar est fashion alors je
n'arrive pas déconner et liberté
d'expression quel brice conneries on est
très contents d'entendre vos conneries
quelquefois je pourrais dire le tribunal
de l'intelligence pourrait condamner de
leurs mots pour son dernier rôle jusque
chez eux d'oxygène
[Applaudissements]
c'est à vous et à 44,4 vainqueur du bras
et professeur de journalisme ce qu'on
[Applaudissements]
n'est pas dans nos manières là je suis
allé chercher dans sa douche sa fille à
prendre des photos or c'est faux on
jalouser lors des combats et revient
d'accord t'as pas à garder occupés doit
d'abord à terre cette histoire on
s'attendre sur mcgill douze fois
championne du monde mon poste renié
relayer des rumeurs sur les réseaux
relève bernard
en tout cas merci moi je vais risquer ma
vie
on se sent bien à travers le monde un
certain nombre de choses et vous connais
vous nous donner des leçons journalistes
me chabert dess vous donner tous deux
connaissent absolument
mais [ __ ] vous stigmatisez équilibré
mais il y avait une baisse qui est
franchement ridicule et labit et qu'est
ce qui vous prend d'aller provoquer un
champion de boxe mais imaginez que le
mec il pète un plomb il vous des
montants 2000
surtout quand même à lehman carte orange
oui voyez la sécu aux tous moi j'ai le
recours à ces d'assumer tous les accords
de courage et de la connerie aussi parce
que je suis un peu entier comme ça mais
j'aimerais savoir si honnête bon buffet
c'est cette émission c'est une grande
gueule
est ce que dans la rue il ya des gens
qui se sont ouvertement manifesté pour
vous casser la gueule la question est
posée à les soucis que j'ai eu c'est des
gens qui tournent autour de fatou j'ai
eu ça plusieurs fois par an comme un
tout ça brille ça avait généré quelques
fois mais maintenant je prends sur moi
j'essaye de me contrôler je fais un
travail énorme à damas s'est très vite
vous pensez vous fait peur quand je lis
parfois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]